amanda mendez is the [ __ ] boxer this
is the dude that trains like an aka and
[ __ ] what are you amanda yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] i say javi and i didn't
write to them
i thought my name was javier mendez for
whatever everybody called me
no no you just say javi and it just
mendes rolls off that's the vasquez [ __ ]
rose gracie's in the house in the
background like the assistant the
assistant manager back there look at
all
smiles what's that buddy what happened
what's the score oh i'm off the check
i've known what the [ __ ] i just gave you
two minute window to check i turn around
and you're staring at me like
you don't know what happened to you
still 21-17 jesus 250.
what's up brother not much great to have
you on the show you know i know you what
10 years i finally find out you're cuban
i'm [ __ ] believing
i'm [ __ ] believable
how's that cuban food and you're always
delicious i'm burping it right now i
can't wait to get home
and you're a rancho cucamongo cuban
that's where you came when you came from
cuba that they take you somewhere else
first no no i came uh we i lived in
armani
most of my life and then i i bought a
house out here when i was like 27. now
when you came to armani from cuba were
the only other cuban people or it was
just you guys no just our family just
our family did you run through a church
first like all the other humans like
you know what i'm talking about right
yeah how the church groups that you
either go to minnesota
no
jersey [ __ ] then you lucked out i lucked
out i lucked out didn't i i never got
religion pushed on me ever
so i i'm kind of glad about that no but
i'm talking about like when you come
this is what happens
when you get when all those
little
and like all these cubans that come now
there's a show there was a show a couple
of years ago it was called barcelo
and it was all the cubans that came on
the [ __ ] raps and what it talked
about was once you get here
you get sponsored and you go to a church
a church takes you in and you're moving
with a family like rudy sarzo when he
came here in the 50s he came before
fidel and he said they moved you around
every year just for like three or four
years until you found where you wanted
to move that's why i was at that school
yeah just a lot of cubans not nate not
me we weren't right to union city we
[ __ ] stayed there
[ __ ] that we were involved in no
chairs no but that's the i just bumped
into a girl and
okay i was in uh portland oregon
and the waitress said to me we have a
cuban girl here who works now and she
came over and introduced us up
she had been in the country for 10
[ __ ] years her english was better
than mine
and i go where did you learn english and
she goes when we came we went to
minneapolis first but they took her
brother her brother's family like they
were older they took him to canada
and they had a because toronto has a
ginormous cuban community really
jai [ __ ] norms right the canadians go
to cuba waiting when they go to cuba
they fall in love with some 16 year old
cuban hooker and they bring them right
back to [ __ ] canadian toronto they
have kids so no toronto has cuban
restaurants
cuban music
you think you're in like [ __ ] union
city they have like three or four blocks
this is in the year 2000
toronto had a three block cuban
neighborhood that was pumping they'd
take it and i met one of fidel's
bodyguards there wow and he was he was
telling me he had a book
and he was gonna do all this [ __ ] and uh
it was really interesting i went to
lunch and he was telling me how fidel
picks up chicks
fidel walks into a restaurant to eat or
he sees a woman that's attractive
and he has one of his guys send over
a [ __ ] walk over to the girl and
bring her a card
and you have to call that number and the
next day a card comes and gets you and
takes it to the doctor to get checked
out
blood tests they check your monkey they
look under your titties everything
and then after that they take you they
buy you dresses they dress you up they
draw your head just like tom cruise in
the scientology show remember they took
the chick shopping
they take you shopping and then they
send you to fidel's house no what the
dog gives you a stabbing keeps you
around for six weeks then you disappear
you cut your head off and you [ __ ]
you become dog food
no this i don't know but he just said
that's how it happens what is it like
for you guys like as like i don't when i
see a another jewish person i don't get
like that excited but when you guys see
how the cuban is it like is it like
there's not that many of them out here i
mean not that i know
i'm starting to meet more brazilian
people because of her but i mean it's
not like cuban people are just running
into me all the time
when i was a kid
and i bumped into [ __ ] somebody
spanish
i get excited really yeah when i was a
kid and i bumped into somebody spanish
i would get very excited when i bump
into anybody cool i'm excited
but
i always want to hear other cubans
people's stories i want to hear how they
were raised
because i know we were [ __ ] crazy
you know but it's amazing you know rose
and i were talking about
cubans and grandfathers and whatever
rule number one rose i'm gonna make your
life [ __ ] simple for you right now
cuban men are like german shepherds
they all got one [ __ ] disorder
and you don't know it till you live with
them but they all got one little
disorder something just don't
communicate right every cuban guy's got
that
my wife has finally dealt with it
lastly my wife
she deals with it she's like that's he
don't bother me at all
you know but every cuban guy the pants
the they all have one saying they'll
torment you with that [ __ ] saying
until you're 80 years old we're talking
about
how javi could be the first cuban black
belt in jiu jitsu
you are probably on paper but if you
know any other cuban they they had a
black belt
they fought chuck norris they broke his
finger you weren't around where the [ __ ]
were you i broke i [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they'll tell you like it's nothing
looking i took chuck norris and i
smacked him four times he left crying
like a little [ __ ] girl i was gonna
ask him to suck my dick but i was busy
that's cuban men you know what i'm
saying because at the end they always
got to suck your dick they suck my dick
but i [ __ ] and beat them up what i'm
saying that's awesome
what's up lisa you bad [ __ ] jew
what's up baby boy i found it i'm i'm
doing a jiu-jitsu tournament with
someone 50 pounds bigger than me so i
had a bad morning this morning man i'm
not
i'm finally now just starting to
even
not even understand ufc but like kind of
grasp it a little bit because before i
was just a fan
but now i like whenever you hear ufc
fight you never hear them say oh i'm
nervous about fighting this guy or oh i
don't want to fight like they're always
like i'll fight anyone anytime and i
i've went and i looked up as facebook
i'm i was nervous i'm nervous man i
gotta be honest i'm not
once you like i was nervous about it
yeah like what do you i mean
what are you nervous about being stuck
in side control being underneath
somebody
he's completely nervous i know lee and
he's completely new you shouldn't be
nervous but that's the thing you
shouldn't be nervous you shouldn't be in
an environment that makes you nervous
like that
well i mean i can't really blame i'm
always nervous like it's just that's who
i am but then it's just i'm not even
afraid of losing i just imagine
i just imagine this guy who's is gonna
probably gonna be around joey's size a
little bit a little bit smaller it's
just gonna take me and like throw me
through the basketball hoop in the gym
where the like i just i i
i don't know i don't i don't know what i
i know he's not going to kill me i don't
know
i mean when when [ __ ] matsuko
taught the grandfather and he came over
from [ __ ] japan
what was [ __ ] brazil what was
jiu-jitsu for tell them what jiu-jitsu
for just to simplify it tell them what
it's for when it's forced for
self-defense well
isn't it for the little guy for the
little guy to be able to beat what is
lee you're little well okay and i know
here's the thing the second the second
you stop
fighting in jujutsu is when you
learn to
you learn to understand what it is
you have to stop fighting you if the
second you start fighting if you
encounter resistance anywhere along your
path because there's a path right
there's a path to escape there's a path
to submit right
as you're going down this path if you're
pushing on something and you encounter
resistance you're going the wrong way
stop immediately and reassess the
situation you should not have to push
your way out
in a way where you're using force and
strength to move leverage can solve that
problem if you understand connection and
you understand leverage
you don't need to work hard and
sometimes the answer is as simple as you
don't go at this particular time the
guy's got you locked down hold down
you're stuck the guy's 300 pounds you
can't move okay except the fact that you
can't move stop fighting
the second you stop fighting the
opponent will start to move guaranteed
what are they gonna do stay there okay
i've got this guy completely controlled
right
he's not moving i feel him give up
i can move now
makes sense and you and when you can
understand that when you are on the
smaller side where you can't move and
you are controlling what he's doing and
when he's doing it
it's
you you you put yourself in predictable
situations and you already know what
you're going to do next does that make
sense you kind of put yourself in a line
you go okay i want to do this i already
know he's going to do that how do i know
he's going to do that because everybody
else that i've put i've done this does
the same thing you start seeing those
patterns have you rolled and every time
you do a certain thing somebody else
always does something to counter
yes or no yes yes so when you understand
what that counter is you have a counter
to the counter
does that make sense yes
so
now now you're dealing with timing the
second that you incorporate timing into
into jiu-jitsu it changes changes
everything changes everything but some
but people don't want to put themselves
in those vulnerable spots
and just wait and see what happens
let somebody mount you and just wait and
see what are they going to do
and you sit there and you go oh he wants
to bring his hand across my neck okay
i'll stop that let's see now now as he's
struck no he's giving up okay now
okay now he's using the other hand i'll
stop that
okay now what's he gonna do and you
start feeling people adjust and boom
that's when you time your escape
that's what we went over today the
escape from the mount just to [ __ ]
around a little bit just in case the guy
got on top
in case
that's what's gonna happen
you know listen
rocky's been on all [ __ ] weekend did
you watch it bro you're watching iraqis
one of the greatest american stories of
all time i watched it for the first time
since i was a kid rocky like rocky
yeah i know i have the movies the
greatest american story of all time
because every time you watch it you
learn something you know there's no
mistake why they keep putting it on
there's no mistake why i got up at six
in the [ __ ] morning thanksgiving
morning and the godfather was on because
they're strong [ __ ] pieces of work
but
and in rocky this [ __ ] in his
mind he was gonna lose the whole fight
right before she comes in the green room
she goes he goes don't leave town
[ __ ] around and she goes bubba and he
goes
you know wish me luck i'm gonna need it
but when he walked in that ring dog it
turned into something else
he just turned into something else and
he realized he could do it
and then you got a scary guy that's why
i did that with you today because one of
the times i was point resistant he threw
me down the big thing he concerned he
had today was that
the takedown to get to the [ __ ] you
know he's never done that contest
he wrestled didn't you say you wrestled
i wrestled a little bit but i was never
good so you understand the concept of
what you have to do
there's a lot of jiu-jitsu people that
have never wrestled they don't wrestle i
feel like it might i don't i don't know
i'll ask your opinion i feel like it
might be hurting me because
like with the single leg i always was
trained to put my head to the side in
between the arm and that leads to a
guillotine i get caught there all day
but you know that right so
if you feel somebody wrapping your neck
that's when you defend okay
so you know that's an option you know
that that's a good possibility right
right okay so anticipate it
and if you anticipate it by just
shrugging your shoulder or grabbing a
little bit higher up on his legs
oh can you just move your phone sorry
um no that's and
i i what i really need i feel like the
worst part of what i do is
i panic it's just
i don't i don't know i don't know
yeah but okay you can sit there and feel
stuck yeah you can sit there and feel
stuck and then panic starts to sit in or
you can sit there and accept that you
that you're stuck
and and just study what the guy's doing
a lot of times people will make
movements maybe it gets better maybe it
gets worse but unless you put yourself
there repeatedly
you're not gonna know right the more you
study the options from each position the
more you study defensively the options
what can the guy do you can knee bar
here you can toe hold here you can arm
bar here you can american here
the second that you understand kind of
where
you are
you start to counter
their their their their first move
remember
okay if you don't want to get caught you
want to be at least two steps behind
being caught does that make sense so you
can have my arm but you can't have your
uh my my arm a high bite on the leg and
the foot and the hip does that make
sense yes do you know what i'm saying
yes yes so
but you can grab my arm the second i
start to feel that foot go okay now i'm
a little bit more aware
does that make sense you have to think
don't get caught first everything else
second
don't get caught first has to be
your
primary mindset don't get caught it
doesn't matter what you do where you
mount me how many times you take my back
doesn't matter don't get
caught and the second you're comfortable
not getting caught
people because you studied people's
behavior in not getting caught oh you
want this and okay so i'll do this i'll
do this up i'll bump you whatever it's
just don't get caught and there's little
systems and little tricks to not getting
caught from certain positions and once
you enjoy that
sometimes i won't even tap people it's
just fun playing defense it's just fun
what it's fun it's like the least
favorite part right now how many years
have you been doing jiu jitsu 17 almost
17 [ __ ] years
but it started clicking on i had this
conversation okay
so
hiton is my my wife's brother and this
guy is just
him and henry are just unbelievable
they're incredible i mean they they took
my jujitsu and just
polished it
polished it just had me thinking
different ways
and
and uh
that whole concept of this defend
enjoy it
if you enjoy being mounted if you enjoy
being there if you really understand
it's a beautiful thing how i can
off-balance you and escape
it's fun
let's see let me see if you understand
what i'm telling you
because i want hobby to know what the
[ __ ] i'm thinking here
my comedy changed completely since i
joined jiu jitsu
completely
a next level because i was so stuck in
my life with kickboxing and blob boxing
and jiu jitsu and
oh
you know uh
punching and striking and all that
stupidity
and i kept watching the ufc
and all the jiu jitsu guys there were
two of them that made my dick card when
i watched them fight and it was joe
lauzon
and when when he first came on he was a
horrible striker
but his jiu jitsu was [ __ ] uh
flashy no no no no the second kid the
brazilian kid i really liked his jiu
jitsu
let's not forget nogara but no girl was
more in japan i didn't get into the ufc
then i got into ufc later on even though
eddie and joe would talk about it and
torment my life i don't want to hear
that [ __ ] because i put it on one time
and i saw tank habit
and i got disgusted this is not the
martial arts i came when i came from
cuba i had the same experience my father
died i was a little half [ __ ] up and
when that guy hit in the head with a
lunch box in central park that was it
that woke the [ __ ] animal up in me my
mom put me in renato laranja's father
ronaldo laranja the one that
his father was my first karate teacher
when i came from cuba how much of a
small world is that are you kidding no
wow what a lineage what a [ __ ]
connection on 90th street and west end
how [ __ ] with the black guys in class
with the hand with the goju karate i was
with lebron joe's father for three
[ __ ] years wow you know so this is
where
so i loved it
but being on my back jiu jitsu guys
wrestling shorts that was never for me
i'm too school cute you know what i'm
saying like when you're cuban hey oh yes
i wanna compile it but i'm so you know
they're [ __ ] crazy so
it wasn't my speed i got sick of [ __ ]
kicking
and there was a jiu jitsu school by my
house which nobody knew about it was a
john jack affiliate i wouldn't embarrass
eddie
that was my first thing i didn't want to
walk into eddie's and have a heart
attack can you imagine his eddie's best
friend comes down here and dies on the
[ __ ] mat let me die somewhere else i
don't want to [ __ ] his [ __ ] are you
really nervous about dying i was [ __ ]
nervous i had never done it before i had
just gotten on my back in the living
room and [ __ ] around like an idiot
you know
just trying to do armbars by myself with
the cat and [ __ ] like that nothing
damien maya once i saw damien mine i was
like wait a second i gotta go on youtube
and watch this [ __ ] he's he's good and
then i met marcelo
with eddie and i started watching his
[ __ ] he's amazing and i started staying
up in a nice smoking pot watching
marcelo and eddie bravo purple belts and
i gotta get into this [ __ ]
but i'm not gonna tell nobody i'm just
gonna go try it
and the first day i wanted to try i
thought i was gonna die
like on the way home i'm like i'll never
do that again
but then everything else came in what
how can i quit
at this age i'm having a baby you know i
want to live i want my wife the baby to
see me doing something
so she learns i have to set an example
you know my age
i kept going back man and then i started
traveling and just going into schools on
the road so nobody would know who i was
right i would just go to school i just
want to do it here one time
and i would have [ __ ] heart attacks i
got to the point i would take aspirins i
would kiss my cats
i would kiss the baby like i was [ __ ]
nervous
because i couldn't get on the bottom
once you grab my neck that's when i
would start
i would start panicking
i hadn't been in those situations in a
long time with the sleepover see you
have to just i think what what what
really offsets panic is just thinking of
the situation don't think of
think of okay what's happening to me
right now except the fact that this is
happening and just think just think your
way through it if you're thinking of an
escape route you're not thinking about
panic
does that make sense yes no no and this
was my first year jiu jitsu
was me laying on the floor and you're
getting on top and me tapping and then i
i flew to burbank to vegas the guy that
really twisted me a little i would ask
questions big john mccarthy on a plane
to vegas i told my situation he goes
listen i got a guy there
i wanted to ask him to leave the first
two years
i mean the guy just didn't have it it
was horrific
i didn't want to take his money anymore
and then one day out of nowhere he just
started clicking now he teaches my
beginner classes you know he goes just
stick it out you you can't breathe tap
compose yourself tie your key and go in
it again and keep going and keep going
and that's what i did and i started and
i joined the
the dj
bjj journal.com so i kept a note every
time i went the things i learned i was
just going through jiu jitsu for a year
and not doing nothing dude i just did
that i did that over the past
over the past four years i've written
down every single thing i know i i write
it down before i go in the shower
when i get in the thing i hang the shirt
i hang the key top i throw the [ __ ]
pants the air out
and i take my shoes off and before i go
in that shower i sit down it says date
time
notes what you learned
yeah just break it down
at least i can set my goals so come on
this time i'm going to go eight times a
month let me ask you something let me
ask you something good
what if you had
the instructor's notes
and you could add your own notes to it
too what do you mean the instructor's
notes
that's what i did i wrote everything i
did down these are my notes these are my
step by step okay these are these here's
your net notes section dude that's what
i've been doing the past four years is
just writing everything down and
organizing it hundred percent in fact
it's almost 2 000 pages
like i with no background for me that
would be great for someone like me who
it would have been great for someone
like me also nothing because after class
i was just thinking about it i don't
remember everything we did in class so
i'm amazed that you go home and like can
write it out oh because i don't return
calls
i don't do nothing all i think about is
that class how i got caught and i think
about what we learned and what i got out
of the class what i'm really going to
use out of the class you know what i'm
saying like what really [ __ ] stuck
out from that class every class should
have that every and they don't every
class does yeah you know what i i
learned this but
i'm older i'm not going to [ __ ]
barambolo my way into your [ __ ]
living room you know what i'm saying the
chance of me bearing bolo on my way into
your living room or slim and none
i know you know what i'm saying i'm
gonna do little things and yeah and look
little things the the little things are
what's gonna you know that you're gonna
have breakthroughs on you know and and
we i mean as far as i'm concerned i've
had breakthroughs you know i can break
through moments breakthroughs and
thinking or you know you just learned
this one way to really finish
you know submission x like this one
thing that you so you start
the more time you're there the more of
those moments you have
and it just grows and grows and grows
and grows and grows it never stops but
you'll start noticing that things that
you did two years ago you're not doing
anymore because your game changes and
your game alters and because as you're
learning new things you're trying new
stuff and and you kind of sweep out the
stuff that you don't
use all the time it's there
it's there you know how to do it if the
opposite opportunity presents itself you
you have that but here's the new stuff
that you're kind of working on you know
so it's always a constant state of
mastering you know i learn something new
and i try to be able to do it and i'm
just attacking it from different
directions and or concepts concepts are
what really have changed my game that's
what hedon and nano were teaching me
concepts it's the concept
the concept then you apply it everywhere
it's not the move it's the concept that
once you understand how leverage works
and connection works once you start
understanding those concepts
your mind gets blown because the
simplest things create you know
incredible power and incredible leverage
simple things that require zero or zero
energy
give you maximum power how is that you
know you just sit there and you wait the
other guy's working his ass off trying
to do something you're just sitting
there like are you done
you know
the goal is to get them tired just get
tired keep seeing the beginning keep
trying to tap in the beginning not only
was my cardio bad but you're [ __ ]
yeah your first nine months you're
[ __ ] you're just moving around then i
watched hodge gracie
smooth the big guy and i watched him
against romulus that that match i
watched that match over and over how
he knows he's going to mount
and he knows he's going to [ __ ] just
choke it
and it's just it's just a finger in the
asleep
it's just a wearer
it's just the way they're like this
and little by little his foot moves in
and he just straightens up and he
adjusts his hips and
you're on the bottom trying to grab and
all of a sudden he grabs one [ __ ]
collar yeah and also that's two minutes
that's two minutes yeah and he's
breathing yeah
and that's true you're on the bottom and
he's just and also the other thing goes
in he ain't even doing nothing yet it's
just in that's that's it that's the part
that blows my mind the most about you
because that's all i want like
i don't care about a move at all right
now i would love to just it looks like
they're almost
like what are those things that can just
roll around like i don't know they it
looks like sonic the hedgehog just
rolling around the mat they like there's
no end to it and every time i do it i
feel like
it's like there's an end well there's
there's a lot of enemies and ends but
then it's just like it's just like
you're just moving one part of your body
but every time i watch like
like
purple belt and up just go it's just
like
it's like they're almost swimming it's
like it's amazing to watch it really is
for a guy it
blows my [ __ ] mind like it blows my
[ __ ] mind yeah
she jiu-jitsu is kind of like one of
those things like i tried paddle
boarding that's fun it's fun as hell you
ever tried that no dude you got to try
it it's fine it's not that hard i didn't
fall that's that's what water bottle
that's what water boxes does understand
the thing the surfboard yeah
dude i would totally want to try and
learn that like in surfing dude that's
freaking that'd be awesome well for me
listen man this is why it helped me and
this is why i love talking to you i i'm
right now i'm nerd now right now
like i'm not a nerd but i nerd out of
when people talk like because
comedy is the same thing
comedy jiu jitsu same [ __ ] thing yeah
same animal you have a thousand jokes
and you don't use no more they work
but you don't use them no more
they got old
you evolved you get yourself in the spot
one night there's chinese people you
whip out a chinese joke from 84.
your phone i'm saying to you
but it's the same thing with comedy you
get rid of that [ __ ] i'm not gonna do an
arm drag no more that's purple belt [ __ ]
i'm man
even though that [ __ ] arm drag
killed [ __ ] for 20 years
you know yeah do you get bored of moves
yeah
do you yeah
after 17 years you get poor yeah
you understand that there's
you understand it's not about the moves
bro
it's about the journey to the submission
how
okay i'm in your guard
okay foot in the hip i'll clear that
let's see what you do now
okay you want it back okay no i won't
give it to you oh you really want this
foot on the head what if i just hold
this here
oh you're going to move your hip that
way okay so i'll just follow you
you want it under nope i won't give you
an underhook no you want to set up it
nope then the third time if they do the
same thing then you go to the face first
it was a chest and then for them to
learn not to do it again you just push
their face nobody likes their face push
so they sit back on the back now they're
looking to possibly um put their other
hook and i go okay no i don't want that
hooking
and i just start blocking and when you
start thinking like that let me just
make this life this guy's life a little
bit miserable let me just see what he's
do trying to do and just take it from
him just don't allow that to happen
you know what i mean don't know how to
happen and just see what he does
oh you sat up okay i'll back out okay
let me see if i do that again and we'll
do it again at what point do you
attack though i won't point like because
i'm people
people do dumb things in the attack you
just fall into attack sometimes oh
great
perfect that was easy
when you understand timing and leverage
bro it makes it easy and the thing is is
the the easiest way to pass the guard is
to not to try and pass the guard
don't try and pass
a lot of times you'll see the oh wow
look at that neon belly he moved himself
out of the way
the best way to escape the mountain is
sometimes tonight is trying to escape
just study what he's doing sometimes
you're both you bumble breath great
so 17 years you're walking down the
street when they whistling minding your
own business
and you see a jiu jitsu school and you
walk over and sign up
what happened
i watched ufc four that's the one that
and then i i'm oh man who's this
brazilian guy so then i went back and
watched you know
two three two and three because uh ufc
one at the time wasn't out i didn't see
that till
much later on and i was wrestling in
college at the time and i'm like i could
do that that that would look fun now
because i
i i could have continued wrestling but i
didn't want to you know i got recruited
at two division one schools and it was
like yeah well you know you have to cut
weight be another weight class below and
i'm like dude i don't want to cut any
more weight and i was already super
already cutting weight
and so i wanted i loved grappling i
always kind of tried to be creative in
wrestling my wrestling coach used to
call me thomas edison award he gave me a
thomas that doesn't work he's always
trying to reinvent [ __ ]
this one's this has been working like
this for 50 years you have to change it
but i was always trying to find that you
know that path that least resistance
because wrestling is so hard dude
everything in wrestling is hard you know
what i mean as i've gotten older i've
applied jiu jitsu concepts to wrestling
it makes a little bit more sense now but
man when i was younger it was just all
go all the time
no timing no no rhythm there's a rhythm
there's a dance in wrestling there's a
dance
you know there's a dance in boxing
you know who's controlling the dance is
the one that's landing the most punches
you know what i mean there's a rhythm
and stand up well i'm sure there is i
don't know what it is because i don't
know that that lifestyle everything has
a rhythm when you watch a basketball
game when you see a team [ __ ]
destroying like lakers in the day
they're on play you watch them
they had a rhythm
they just it was just a [ __ ] rhythm
you know sometimes when
i think it was just legit
jiu jitsu is the rhythm of everything
yeah and when you see yoga well done
it's kind of it's art it's an art it's
another rhythm yeah that's you know it's
an art man and everybody kind of has
every artist every black belt is an
artist you could say
has their own interpretation hixon's
interpretation is different than mine
because of my experience his background
my background so it doesn't you know
you know hoiler same thing you know all
these guys that bring these different
backgrounds they all interpret the same
information differently i feel
because they start to get gain their own
input
of their own experience and things that
have worked for them that's why you see
the differences in styles
so same arm bar you know same thing
there's three different ways you can
accomplish the same goal you sometimes
pick the one that you like the most same
goal
same goal
untangling the arm same goal but man
there's a couple different ways to do it
and
makes it easy okay got that okay now i
know i do that next move on to the next
thing you know so that's in my pocket
next time i get there okay untangle's
easy
you know that's how you got to put it
together
that's how you got to put it together so
you walk into this jiu jitsu school
what's this guy's name oh uh rodrigo
medeiros he was uh one of carlson's
black belts and you're starting as day
one starting there's day one but i
wrestled through college you know so i
already had a wrestling background um
i was there vitor went right right after
he fought tank avid vitor's training
there marilla bustamante was there um
valleji ismail was there
uh
who else was there
the the big guy carlomba no there was a
hatto there
no um what was bahato's friend uh
uh passed away
franco franco di camargo franco de
carmen so now you're walking there is a
white balance i'm like who are all these
guys in their bikinis over here because
they had the speedos they're walking out
in the middle where they're no shirt on
no shoes just speedos out there
with a bunch of brazilian dudes
so
i walk in i'm like who are these guys
hole in the wall allej's head went
through the ho through the wall
anyways
and um the style just clicked for me at
the time the style definitely clicked
for me at the time
carlson styles very aggressive
very flow based so uh
so a lot of things in combination
tricky transitions stuff like that
no real no real concept of connection it
was mostly speed and power from from
i felt comfortable in the style and and
that's what i felt that i was using
um
you know and and okay whether or not you
could do that to a larger person i mean
i usually could but it was it wasn't
easy
it wasn't easy you should be able to be
bigger people almost the same as you be
smaller people same concept same
leverage for the most part just takes
longer time because they're stronger
so uh i did the tournament circuit
that's where i competed against eddie
so i heard a few times yeah you and i
were like battles yeah purple belt you
started yeah blue ball and purple belt
yeah and you've known eddie how long
i mean i probably met eddie within six
months no less than six months of me
just starting to train jiu jitsu so 17
years
yeah i've known a long time
and seen his evolution and his game and
his transformation you know because he
documented everything
document and everything which i thought
i i have done also now finally but he's
been putting it out along the way so you
see his journey
you see what he was thinking in 2003 you
know what i mean what was he thinking
how is he thinking how he's evolved if
you know him now right
it's like a like a
like your history
so he's doing great he's done a great
job with that and and i applaud that i
thought it was great when did you
incorporate striking into your game
i mean two i mean i started in 97 i had
my first mma fight at 98.
so within the first year so i was a blue
belt so
i got my belts
relatively quickly
in jiu jitsu i got a black belt in five
and a half years so that's pretty fast
for most people
especially at the time back then they
were promoting like super slow
you'd get sandbagged forever
so
so uh were you already a pro fighter
like were you going seven days a week or
like no it was a very different time it
was i mean i trained jiu jitsu and then
i trained with the boxing gloves on here
and there and tried to take you down and
once i got people down there was no
stand-ups at the time
so your ass was down your ass all i
needed was three takedowns because i got
you down i can
stay there as long as i want there's no
such a thing as a stand-up the ufc
incorporated that to
increase the pace of the fight you know
what i mean
imagine if there's no stand-ups why
wouldn't you be able to stand up that
doesn't make sense what do you mean like
because in wrestling you can stand up
why can't you stand up and why wouldn't
they let you stand up this this whole
evolution of standing up off the bottom
this is not has now been around forever
oh this has been in in the past like
five years or so i mean guys have gotten
really good at that [ __ ]
like you see the evolution of mma if you
know it's history same thing with jiu
jitsu you see the evolution
see the evolution
or de-evolution some some of us call it
do you get mad at some of like the new
i don't know not fancy stuff but like
stuff like
like kind of like the dh rule in
baseball just like when people change
um
i don't like that they're starting to
add and change belts i don't like that i
like the tradition of the way it was
certain organizations started adding and
changing belts
changing rank and i don't like that at
all
you know i think
i think um
that's something that's like sacred
ground you know what i mean and you
shouldn't be doing it well when they add
or whatever about this for more money
it's like type one though but that's
exactly what five belts and now it's got
92 [ __ ] belts that's why it's that's
why well i don't charge for bell
promotions well i charge for my test for
blue belt but i don't charge like kids
like i don't charge them to promote the
kids you know what i mean that's not
something you charge for
i don't believe that
so now if you lose your belt or
something okay yeah but but i mean you
know do you know what i'm saying right
now i understand what you're saying no i
get what you're saying
it's just uh
like anything else jiu-jitsu has become
a big-time business
you know
sometimes sometimes things aren't all
about money right and we know that but
for some people they don't know you know
it's like when i joined the karate it
was 35 a month
you paid for your ghee you got the patch
and you were good to go
i remember 10 15 years ago when i first
moved to l.a i went to a suboxo thing
here
every time i went in there they were
hitting me up for 35 dollars or
something oh you got to buy the books
you got to buy the v8 sets you got to do
this you got you don't have to do [ __ ]
but this it became a business you know
it's become a business and
uh
but who gives a [ __ ] now
i'm interested in this fighting thing
okay 98. you have a fight now when do
you go pro open-handed open [ __ ] hand
open hand
that [ __ ] hurts
i did i did a tournament the first three
fights i had were in one night
boom boom boom i believe yes if it
wasn't my first three
yeah i think my first three fights were
was a tournament and the eight-man
tournament i made it to the finals so i
had three fights in one day
getting smacked in the face well or well
uh trying not to get schneiderlin
you know i mean this is very raw this is
early like you ever seen like the early
tap out videos
remember the old ones that they used to
do like it was like that around that
time some of those those guys were all
our buddies the top out guys they were
down in orange county which is guys
right absolutely no yeah no they were on
like sam bernardino area wow yeah so if
you look at one of their first posters
i'm i'm the little wrestler using the
poster
that's crazy that's great it started
no it's it's been a [ __ ] crazy ride
but for you like i just saw
i you know like when you pulled up you
have the strike base i've spoken to rose
before one of the improvs one night and
she was saying you should go down and
see him it's a complete different
[ __ ] game yeah you're a really
interesting guy like you
before i was [ __ ] mesmerized he
really had me going before
because you're saying the truth you're
looking at you're looking at it from a
17 year old
a guy who's been doing jiu jitsu for 17
years yeah but you three more years you
become you'll become a master like i
guarantee when you're doing jiu jitsu 20
years you'll look back
and go what the [ __ ] was i thinking at
10 years i suck bass
that's how i look at kami now yeah at
the 10-year mark i was already in l.a
ten years
i was already hadn't been on mad tv
you know i thought i was the king of the
world i look at those tapes now i want
to light them on fire
but you know what you see you saw that
with chris rock he said george carlin's
one of my favorite comedians i love
george carlin but as his [ __ ] got older
he got way [ __ ] better yeah he got
way better he got way better and you saw
the evolution it's like i mean he was
good here but this show was you know
amazing you know and you said joe's the
same thing you're going to be the same
thing you're going to see revolution
doesn't mean that your fans
your fans are going to grow with you
which is a that's awesome they see you
they accept you for who you are they
love you and they're there for your
journey you know
it's an amazing thing it really is it's
a journey it's a journey this comedy
[ __ ] is a [ __ ] journey you know
you're talking about this eight-man
tournament
and i'm thinking to myself in those days
there was no blood test
no they didn't wear [ __ ] gloves
commissioned the mats had sperm on them
from the ref getting this dick sucked
the week before
you know and you do this no commissions
no commission and you flip this and this
is like when i had to go to rock springs
wyoming to do comedy and share a room
with another guy and smell his feet and
farts all night in the middle of night
he would just get up in the middle night
and light up a [ __ ] cigarette in the
room
you know i got a story about that oh my
god it's the it's such a
you know the first four or three years
of anything
you're just doing it to suffer in a way
and you think back like i did that [ __ ]
was i [ __ ] crazy i could have gotten
killed
hobby you could have gotten killed
you know not by anything uh you fall
over
an armbar you think too much you have a
[ __ ] stroke whatever the [ __ ] it is
and you you put yourself in those
positions for what you loved and what
you believed in
which is the [ __ ] art you didn't even
know
believe me believe me i i did not fight
for money
especially early on
we're doing because it's fun we're good
at it you know what i mean
so i mean that's that's why i was doing
it it was it was fun man it was fun to
go to the casinos it was fun to
walk around with the belt it was fun but
believe me we were not making money now
these guys now are starting to make some
money which is awesome
in the very beginning
i didn't make a dime to well i made a
dime after a year of doing comments
getting 50 a week to host every tuesday
you know how old are you then i was i
started comedy when i was old
i started comedy when i was uh whatever
the [ __ ] it is 20 something 32
32 32 maybe wow 32 42 50. no
i started coming at 28. 20. but i didn't
get serious till 31.
i was just divorced i had every credit
card taken away
i had a [ __ ] call i got jacked what
do you call that [ __ ] when they come and
reboot repo you go ahead and accurate
attack where they repo
i had nothing so i said i got nothing to
lose
this is the time to do what i really
want to do because i got nothing to lose
what do i got to lose from what i've
heard from comedians is they they love
their job man you guys love your job you
have fun at your job and that's i mean
man
it's not it's not even about money if
you're having fun man
if you can sustain a life or you're cool
and and you can do something that you
like doing man it's
i i'm very blessed
to be able to wake up and put pajamas on
and
go go have fun with my friends what were
your options when you were 20.
work at a grocery store
stocking shelves well you were in
college
yeah you went to college on a [ __ ]
scholarship so you at least really got a
college degree i i went i went well
remember no i didn't get a scholarship
from high school i was gonna get i was
gonna get a scholarship after junior
college
so i was already like 21.
so did my first two years at mount sac
junior college
so
you know
it was funny because i had options
you know i had a bunch of options but
now i had felonies
so i was like well that takes away a ton
of options
but i could still do something you know
and i kept thinking about the comedy i
kept thinking about the concept
something something something drew you
to it you know
well
you know what drew me to it bro that
it's at night and i had my days
that's what i really liked about it and
i started asking more questions about
like why would i do this [ __ ] i like my
mom had a bar
so i saw her in the daytime you know she
could take care of me in the daytime she
was around the daytime you know i liked
that i didn't like that people had a
[ __ ] work in the daytime
i [ __ ] hated that i hate i hate that
kids have to go to school it's freaking
seven a.m gotta get up
[ __ ] them no they gotta go to school
[ __ ] that [ __ ] cuban stuff come on
go to school and send it i don't wanna
see your rotten ass still six little
cocktails no that's what i'm saying why
can't they start at 10 you know [ __ ]
that no they're gonna start at six man
cause that toughens them up for the
future machine when they wake up and you
gotta put i don't know when i was a kid
my mom would put this is how cuban we
were
she would put emotive cod in my orange
juice you know what the most of avocado
is and also the goat what is that that's
a most of a [ __ ] cod
it's a cod fish
and it's they took the whole fish and
they blended with [ __ ]
you know everything that's good for you
and it becomes a cream
and your mom puts it on a spoon
and gives it to you and you're like
it's like e when he eats edibles
and your mom goes go ahead spit it out a
[ __ ] smackdown you're gonna have to
eat another one
so if you spit it out don't worry about
it you're still gonna have to drink i'll
[ __ ] sit here with you till 10
o'clock i don't give a [ __ ]
and she would you know and then finally
mommy put it in the orange juice she
started putting the freshly squeezed
orange juice and i would just [ __ ]
down it
you know that's how cuban we were and
then she would look under my eyelids
and if my eyelids didn't have enough
blood under there she would have a
[ __ ] heart attack though [ __ ]
cuban cuban people that doing that [ __ ]
paula's mom gave her an emulsive of god
yeah yeah
emotive of cod when you're a kid it
takes you from level a to level b jack
it takes you to two [ __ ] different
levels it toughens you up
and you don't get [ __ ] sick
you don't get sick your [ __ ] immune
system's on fire
you're drinking the heart of the fish
every [ __ ] morning
for breakfast are you [ __ ] kidding me
or what
that is just i can't believe more and
now they [ __ ] it up for kids they made
a raspberry flavor and orange flavor but
it still smells like it still tastes
like dick
the blood of the fish is still [ __ ]
in there oh god i've never even heard of
that but that sounds
put the picture up from your friends
here get the computer [ __ ] working in
oh my god what the [ __ ] you're sitting
there all done stuff that they win
no we lost and it looks like gronk's
hurt so
you lost yeah yeah 22 to 21
30 to 24. oh my god they got upset in
denver in the [ __ ] snow
granikowski's heard it's all over and
[ __ ] what's going on thank god they
didn't put any money on that's right
thank god
no most did you put any money on that
ronda rousey fight no no i don't know
about that
i was doing homework in my business i
was in san francisco working i was in
jersey working oh my god
somebody makes me do oh please it was
like 22 000 a [ __ ] three
jiu jitsu just uh every time i watch the
ufc
i this is look what it looks like it's
none of these
see that red one that's the [ __ ] one
now that's raspberry flavored the thing
in the middle
but no no
you got to go to old school
and most of a [ __ ] when i see it i go
blue that's how you'll know
see that fisherman that's the
[ __ ] right there look at the ad
oh no they don't even have it no more
and most young that good
that [ __ ] kids that will that's what
makes your dick
harder than [ __ ]
when you're like seven or eight your
dick gets hard like once a month hard
you don't even use call for your mommy
mommy what's happening and your mom
comes she don't even know i don't know
oh my god it's like you're the exorcist
that's like compatible as milk is that
true yeah
no that means it tastes as good as milk
no no no don't this is gonna [ __ ]
milk that's a lie
it tastes like milk with fish joints
juicing it that's what it tastes like it
tastes like milk
and it's clear it's a little thick
it's thick
it's thick
i'm thinking i'm going to get it because
you know what i'm going to start giving
it to my daughter oh no why not oh
you'll toughen that [ __ ] up that that
doesn't really work yeah it really works
man oh somebody as well so why don't you
take it now because i don't need that
type of protection in my life that's
like if you're [ __ ] people with aids
and you're eating [ __ ] and [ __ ]
[ __ ] people with ages yeah if you're
[ __ ] hanging out with people with
hepatitis b and [ __ ] like that that's
when you drink that [ __ ] nothing will
happen to you
you know you're hanging out with normal
people like you and and [ __ ]
harvey you know and rose i'm okay i
don't need that type of protection
but when you're hanging out with [ __ ]
innocents you know and people are the
savages charlie sheen
this one i was a kid this when i was a
kid
my mom i was always sickly so my mom
would give me this and it kept building
me up and i kept you know like a [ __ ]
added to my [ __ ] craziness
she would give me stakes and emulsive of
god
cubans bro they toughen you up when
you're a kid that's the beauty of our
culture that sees like there's rumors
that if you started acting gay around
killing people in the 40s they'd take
your shark fishing the parents would
take your shark fish
you have to go out there i don't see no
sharks
throw them off the [ __ ] boat
so you know it's just the weirdest
culture they're the weirdest [ __ ]
bunch of people man
you hear some crazy [ __ ]
so that's that's why that's what i'm
thinking lee what's the matter with you
sitting there all [ __ ] nothing
i was thinking like when you were angry
about the belts like what does your
black belt mean like like
when you see how long did it take you to
get the black belt five and a half
five and a half [ __ ] years i mean
what do you got to complain about oh i'm
not gonna you broke the [ __ ] record
bj broke the bj broke the record jesus
christ hobby five and a half [ __ ]
years
i've been a white belt for eight years
you haven't trained not eight years no
no no
i'm just teasing you but uh
five and a half years
now you were tearing it up in the
circuit like you were just coming back
and they'd give you another belt well
not not exactly
from
okay so my first the first time any saw
me
i was
a white belt my instructor said you're
doing the blue belt tournament
i'm like am i blue belt and he's just
like no i've been training like three
months
and i'm like okay so you want me to do a
blue belt tournament but i'm not a blue
belt and he's like yep
so we went up to santa cruz
i think it was like the second or third
u.s open it was like the second one
um now they're like on like 19 or
something like that or 20.
and uh i won my division and along the
way i beat the guy that apparently won
the pan ams
in the
finals so three months later i got my
blue belt like three months later so
then like during my blue belt
years
i won like 16 tournaments or something
like that then then i got a purple belt
which was a year later so i was like
competing
whenever i could
and then uh
purple bell i did like there's less
matches for purple belts back then so i
did like 12 tournaments and i won all of
them
and then
so that was a year and a half at purple
and then
i got my brown but so at three years i
was a brown belt and then i was two and
a half years as a groundhog
what was the first promotion you fought
for
neutral grounds are they here california
yeah i think they're like in torrance
area out there
you never went to japan and all that one
i didn't or you did go i beat uh romina
in japan
and wasn't like what was it what league
was it i don't even know shootouts oh
[ __ ] yeah look at you hobby [ __ ]
unbelievable
shows up with croquettes and [ __ ]
we burped into my sleep apnea masks
yeah so
man i stumbled on upon mma dude you know
it wasn't like i i woke up and i'm like
i'm going to train to be a fighter
that's not the way it evolves no no no
that's not because you got to look at
the evolution of the sport and i was
just kind of riding that wave so as guys
got better i tried to get better when i
saw people starting to do this more you
make adjustments in training so
to accommodate so things nothing i've
never seen a shock like i don't know if
i would have fought if i went into like
an mma gym today
and just
okay i want to be a fighter i don't know
if i could do that right now i mean the
way it happened for me i wouldn't change
it for anything
i wouldn't want to do it now i i liked
the way it went for me
you know what i mean i liked that ride i
mean
you just you know
you just meet so many cool people along
the way early in their career you know
what i mean
and um
you know become friends with all these
cool fighters you know it was it was a
fun journey man it was a fun journey and
a lot of it started here in southern
california so you were right there
i mean i don't know the history of the
histories i just hear different stories
and it seemed like a lot of [ __ ] fun
just you know and eddie all those years
yeah you know like you competing with
eddie and
now look where eddie is at look where
you're at you have your school he has
this school it's just a [ __ ]
and again it's like comedy you know what
i'm saying 20 years ago i was up in
seattle with josh wolf he gets on
chelsea lately
i get the podcast everybody's [ __ ]
happy now we hang out we talk
you know it's it's it's a [ __ ]
journey that is just uh
i don't know and i even enjoyed the
bumps like all those years that i
starved and
things weren't [ __ ] kicking i would
do them all over again lisa yeah why not
you grow from yeah i [ __ ] grew like a
[ __ ] i it took me a while i had
about i had a big bump
you know i had a big big bump in my
career
you know it's funny that you said that i
one day i was out i don't know what the
[ __ ] i was doing some guy came up to me
it's like hey you remember me
we met doctor
and i'm like oh yeah whatever you know
what happened he goes hey when do you
want us to do a cd
seriously joe
that's what happened oh really
and he goes when do you want to do a cd
and i don't even know what you're
talking about he goes you should really
do a cd all right whatever i'll see you
soon and he kept calling me did you take
the cd did you take the cd
no i didn't he goes why don't you go to
a [ __ ] place
and uh he goes i'll charge you whatever
you could some guy would tape to see
defeat at the time i was working on
national lampoon radio did you know that
lee no i was what is this this is on
sunset we drive by it every night and we
go to the comedy store you know that
crazy lady dances across the street yeah
right when you get a little candy right
when you get off laura canyon right in
that building there used to be national
lampoon radio upstairs and i would do
the martial arts movie minute
i would talk about sunny sheba bruce lee
or whatever the [ __ ] i would talk about
so uh what the [ __ ] are we talking about
about um
working on the radio taping cd with joel
taping the cd with joe and the guy
that's funny you were saying that before
he had been
he did all these remixes for led
zeppelin the guy was beat up the guy was
like [ __ ] 60. he had done every drug
in the [ __ ] world
and i became friends with the guy
you know nobody would talk to him at the
studio i always talked to him about
music he brought me recordings so he
goes i'll tape the cd for you
and i [ __ ] take the cd and i sent it
to joel and we put it up for sale and
every three months i get a check for
eight dollars
six dollars
four dollars and then the podcast thing
started coming up
then i think we taped another cd you
know we taped especially
i looked at the other day it is so badly
we taped it 10 10 of 10. oh i wasn't
around for that that was right before i
came around with felicia you have to see
how bad this is
you have to see how bad this is
you really do have to see how bad i'm
going to send it to you you're going to
go was that you
five years ago and i was already
headlined evolved man
you know and this is something happened
it really [ __ ] clicked
and i see it now
when i go to jiu jitsu the only reason
why i kept going to jiu jitsu because i
was so bad at kami in the beginning
i knew that if you stuck with us
something good would happen
do you know what i'm saying if i would
have started jiu jitsu at 25 i wouldn't
have stuck with it
there's no [ __ ] way
everything's evolving man everything's
evolving when i when i first started jiu
jitsu it's like gracie jiu jitsu was
like [ __ ] impossible to get a hold of
unless you
you know bought tapes it's like where
can i get this information there's no
schools there's schools everywhere now
there's youtube you can learn moves on
youtube there's on youtube
it was like every team had their um
secret moves you know their style you
know
so you had to do what you know you had
to watch out for that team style and no
team
would share the information with anybody
it was crazy
it was crazy that's what i went through
with jiu jitsu when it started it was
you know there was this team and that
team and that's that team over there you
don't cross train and
you don't talk to them yeah
they're from rio yeah we're from [ __ ]
the other part of brazil it was that
territorial yeah i mean everybody got
along
but
yeah
why is he here it's funny i always see
that on eddie's posters for his eddie
posters he's like oh everyone welcome
i'm like why wouldn't everyone be
welcome dude yeah
that's crazy yeah some people only do
seminars with their affiliations
yeah
eddie's eddie's got man eddie what
eddie's done with 10th planet is so cool
he's got such a cool group of people
over there you know i remember when it
was at the bomb place
on santa monica across from the place
that sells you you like that place
i know you ate there or something you
told me which place
the northern food company or some [ __ ]
on santa monica boulevard
do you remember where the bomb squad was
no i never went to the bomb squad
the bomb squad was his first tenth
planet it was across the street from
i never went in there i heard people
when they got sick for [ __ ] days
from what the food
oh i've been lucky i've never gotten
food poisoning so that wasn't me you
know two people i know got food
poisoning over the weekend both eating
mexican food john salami and eddie brown
oh really eddie bob is at home right now
[ __ ] miserable both dying
he ate tacos in san diego no i
if not he'd be here eddie probably would
have been here oh [ __ ] why not rose's
here yeah what the [ __ ] family saying no
you got sick and salami's sick oh really
i don't know that
salami's got food poisoning too so
beware
eating [ __ ] mexican tacos
i thought i was gonna get food poisoning
yesterday i went to that place right up
this right up the corner and
as i was in there i was like ooh this
place doesn't look good but i was like
[ __ ] it i just got a couple tacos
you got to be [ __ ] careful now bro
people ain't doing food [ __ ] right no
more that filthy out what happened
something
my
that was yours for sure yeah i think so
that's [ __ ] crazy you're gonna put
some tony bennett on or what absolutely
yo daddy not on me and [ __ ]
sunday night november 29th and [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] up i'm done
new england [ __ ] losers i know you're
the kiss of death
oh yeah [ __ ] it's your fault i
wasn't there to watch jiu-jitsu
a little comedy tonight people will mix
it all in
who's that
no we don't take [ __ ] brexit
let me do some shout outs and we'll get
us out of here my girl rose has to pee
here zach brody
what the [ __ ] is going on
the bathroom's right there
reigning bossier i'm sorry for your loss
gil salcedo
alex zamora david k
jeff clark jim burgess
brendan rigsby
and eddie brancaccio i love you
[ __ ] eddie b's in old
north bergen new jersey buddy of mine
living in orlando florida down there
with [ __ ] mickey mouse
what's going on lisa what happened this
weekend what did i miss
nothing thanksgiving was [ __ ]
thanksgiving was great have a nice
thanksgiving
i didn't do dick
okay i got invited to go to two places i
went to jiu jitsu at 10.
which was fun we got donuts we got
donuts afterwards and then [ __ ] lee
went home and he came back like 1 30 we
ate some turkey and he went to his
girlfriend's house and i sat there with
the baby and my wife and the [ __ ]
sleeping pills came up in the turkey
because the turkeys always come with
sleeping pills
and that was it i slept i got up like at
six people were beeping me where the
[ __ ] are you i ain't going nowhere god
suck i'm staying in tonight i'm getting
the old rose
you just get [ __ ] bored you know
you're like i can't i'm i was on the
road five out of six weeks i was on
planes
you know three of them to the east coast
that sucks the [ __ ] energy well what
yeah i hate to fly back if i go east
coast i try to stay there for a little
bit no i gotta come home i miss the baby
you know i miss the baby i miss my wife
so when i leave on thursday i come home
on sunday morning
so i come home in the middle of the
night like a [ __ ] burglar i'm walking
around tonight at four in the morning i
just got in there 12 30. thank god i
don't drink no dude no drugs or nothing
i mean i smoke 15 joints and i drink
[ __ ] decaffeinated coffee
but that's the extent of it
i get tired guys that's a lot of [ __ ]
hours man then during the week i get up
at five
so the secret is i gotta go home and
fall asleep at ten but who goes to sleep
at [ __ ] ten
my wife goes to sleep at times i stay up
till one and get peace of mind i watch
tv i make notes i try to write [ __ ]
jokes
i talk to this [ __ ] gazoo you know i
go to bed at one one thirty one one
thirty so i'm walking around that
[ __ ] five after three days you're a
zombo you got a headache and [ __ ] from
not sleeping
and i can't take sleeping pills you know
i just can't do it i can't do it i can't
wake up i can't wake up off what about
melatonin
that [ __ ] wears off after [ __ ] four
days
after four days you're back to square
one today i saw something really [ __ ]
interesting i saw the last 24 hours of
michael jackson anybody see that show
yeah
god the [ __ ] damn
well i never even heard about it god
[ __ ] damn what that poor kid was
going through
michael jackson
yeah towards the end man he had such a
bad addiction
he was taking pills to wake up
and [ __ ] to go to sleep
but the night he died he took three
heavy duty [ __ ] sleeping pills
like three [ __ ] that would put us to
sleep for 12 hours
he took a a short-term one a long-term
one and a minute medium-term one they
were called benzidines or something like
that
and or they had benzidines in them some
[ __ ] craziness and that the guy's
like look at these three pills alone
would [ __ ] somebody up for 15 hours
this guy was still [ __ ] awake
that's when they put in that pro hypnos
[ __ ] the pro [ __ ] whatever that [ __ ]
is that they give to what they when they
use that for for surgeries and [ __ ]
but
yeah was it
pro football whatever
so they he was supposed to he only
administered 25 milligrams he said that
after he admits he put 25 milligrams
michael jackson got up and poured half
the [ __ ] bottle in there
that's how crazy this [ __ ] was
when it took him to go to sleep i took i
took um
i took i i i did some research on like
drug addiction on the brain
man i have a different respect for
addicts man because
it's a strong enough drug and and
granted the mistake was made to start
drug to begin with and but but you can
get addicted to different kinds of
things so sometimes it's out of your
control or you know you just don't know
but
it basically hijacks your brain the drug
the the dopamine that's released by your
brain
which causes pleasure
the addiction to that pleasure you can
say for that particular individual is so
high that it puts you know
it puts that drug getting that drug
feeling that high feeling that happiness
you know more important than anything
and then if you stay on it long enough
then
it's permanent
you have to take that much just to be
normal to feel like you're not crashing
and man you think about that that's
rough
you never did hard drugs no
no never did hard drugs or anything but
yeah i was i was i was looking into that
into into what is addiction why do you
know and you just start you're just like
jesus christ like it's it's it's
something different man
my addiction jacked my brain
but i still wanted to do comedy
like i was a functioning [ __ ] addict
you're following me like i still did my
comedy i still did movies i still did tv
i still wrote
i just knew how to do an eight ball and
how to [ __ ] hide it you knew it when
you saw me this motherfucker's pale
you know why is he so [ __ ] pale
people knew it you know in your mind
you think people don't know i just
watched that movie with denzel
washington when he plays the pilot yeah
oh that's a great movie right and he
flips the plane how [ __ ] up was he
he this guy partied all [ __ ] night
did a couple lines of coke to straighten
up and got on a plane and flew it that's
a reality guys
that's a [ __ ] reality people do it
all the [ __ ] time for 10 years i
walked around getting on planes you know
going into hotel rooms walking out of
that floor foaming from the mouth like
lamar odom you know i did all that
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] got on planes
thinking i got on a plane one time in
1987
i was so [ __ ] cooked up
in those days there wasn't no tunnels to
the plane
do you follow them saying here like you
got exposed to the outside you walked
onto the street if it was raining it was
raining i remember being in kennedy
airport and people with jackets freezing
with snorkels walking to the plane and
me walking through the plane with a
[ __ ] and me walking to the plane with
a t-shirt like this rose
with steam coming out of my back like i
[ __ ] was an angel you understand me
floating into the [ __ ] plane
that's how [ __ ] up i was
i had the jacket in my hand sweating
profusely
steam was coming out of my [ __ ] back
i had been snorting blow for three days
didn't stop in fact the third day the
pipes went
we snorted coke with candles and three
feet of [ __ ] water walking around
like scuba man this is addiction right
there
me and four other guys in the chick with
a skirt on i had never seen before you
can't write this [ __ ]
i got on the plane
and before the plan even took off i got
up so many times to go to the bathroom
this is great and i think about this
that this whole day now
then i got up so many times i was
embarrassed so i would just take the
little dish
the little [ __ ] thing that you popped
down and i put the blanket over my head
and i do coat under the thing and i pop
the blanket off and make believe like
i was just under there hanging out
that's how [ __ ] crazy i was when i
was in 1987.
that's how crazy i was i think about
that [ __ ] now
but then i think about michael jackson's
[ __ ] that's next level because that
that's a those are like painful sleeping
pills oh my god and he was on him
first though do you know that
[ __ ] had a wig
that was a wig that was stitched on was
he bald bald
bald like [ __ ] lisa ball because when
he burnt his head in the pepsi
commercial the burns were so deep
he can't even grow hair there he you
could see during the
pepsi commercial as they're pulling them
off that this is on fire right in the
middle like a [ __ ] little old man
like he had a yarmulke there
he was a black julie did you see that by
god god burnt them there
from all the money he had and [ __ ] burnt
them sizzled that little juice spot
there and did you see the documentary
that they were filming as he like right
before he passed away okay that was
great but do you know why why let me
tell you the [ __ ] story to the
documentary
here you go guys
the rehearsals were going so bad
that they were thinking of pulling the
plug on the tour
the guy that came out during the tour
the the dude that came out during that
movie
yeah that guy sent an email to the
producers in england saying dog
this ain't gonna work
he ain't gonna do two nights never mind
50 [ __ ] nights
oh my god he was addicted to the time of
his death to demerol he would go to a
doctor's office right in beverly hills
and they'd shoot him with [ __ ]
demerol every day two three shots a
[ __ ] day
okay that's why his lungs and his
breathing was so bad his cardio
was so bad at the end he couldn't even
do the [ __ ] dance moves no more
so what he did was he went and he got
hooked up with ephedrine
is that what you're taking ephedrine
oh i don't know i don't even know what
that is he went and took like straight
up efferdin
which is like an adrenaline boost
and the day they said tape
tape that
so we could see it and send it to us
that's the documentary [ __ ] oh my god
he did 40 minutes
and it was perfect
they green lit it they said fine that's
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] so what you're
telling me is for the last two weeks
he's been coming in here all [ __ ] up
and today he comes in jumping up and
down like johnny [ __ ] piper
so they found bro when they [ __ ] did
his autopsy
he had
two pages of drugs in his system
two pages guys just just pill after pill
after pill with it
it was [ __ ] crazy it's a different
type of addiction you know why he was
going up to people at parties
what do you do sir i'm a doctor oh my
god can i ask you a question i can't
[ __ ] sleep at night what does your
physician say
well my physician has put me on this
this this and this so right away you
want to be the [ __ ] doctor to save
michael jackson
come to my office tomorrow let me check
you out and do a thing he had that scam
going with eight [ __ ] doctors in
beverly hills i bet he didn't even have
to go he was michael jackson he was
probably getting he was getting pills
sent to him
from all over the [ __ ] world
it's it's it's andy
you know when i saw this today it's i
couldn't live that i could never live
that i'm surprised he made it to 50.
he's been hooked since 1986 1987.
but what started him i mean that i mean
aren't you isn't anybody curious about
what caused him to start
whatever yeah because look look at him
as a little kid a cute little kid
and then how does it get to
[ __ ] he's a cute little kid he's
getting abused from his father you know
i mean
listen guys there's a thousand [ __ ]
stories
but there's a thousand stories to how
you react to them
you know what i'm saying i knew growing
up
what drugs were about i knew growing up
what drugs are about abby
my mom did coke i didn't [ __ ] like it
i used to say wipe your [ __ ] nose and
i wouldn't talk to her for a day or two
i didn't [ __ ] like it
i always had a thing that i was always
in a smoke pot i liked it i like smoking
pot and listening to music i never
dreamt to put nothing up my [ __ ] nose
that was not who i was and i was [ __ ]
15 12.
but something happened when i was 16
that switched the [ __ ] button what
could it have been i snorted coke before
my mom died so you can't blame it on
that what was it like don't [ __ ]
blame it on that don't even you know
don't blame it you know everything that
we do
we blame something on
the only person you could blame for
being hooked on anything is yourself
i don't blame nobody i can't blame i
can't be mad at nobody for getting
hooked on anything but my [ __ ] self
listen man i gambled
i gambled and i [ __ ] hated paying the
bookmaker
on thursdays it bothered me to death
we've discussed this a thousand times
i had a lot of [ __ ] bad habits
growing up that i did
but the one i justified was cocaine
because in my mind i got something from
it i didn't get nothing from it
in my mind it was better than gambling
in my mind it was better than going to a
bar and spending 100 hours in my mind
god knows what that i know
that knowing amount of drugs is worth
dying over
i know that i know that once you get to
that [ __ ] point tricks your brain man
he was 400 million in debt
no
that's why he had to do this tour how do
you get a form
this tour was going to [ __ ] justify
everything
just what was the name of the tour this
is it
right
wasn't that the name of the [ __ ] door
yeah at least this is
this is it this is it if this don't work
this is it michael jay
you lose the circus you lose the museum
at the time of his death he was 400
million in debt and he had 25
lawsuits against him
26 lawsuits against him for all kinds of
students and now he made two billion
dollars last year
he's the highest paid debt guy [ __ ]
ever ever like he brought back [ __ ]
everything
it's so gross
remember you're more people like that
you're more you have more work dead than
you are alive at that point he was
probably too much of a nuisance at that
point
like not now i didn't know he owed that
much and pissed that made people off now
i think even
like did anyone talk about it being like
a hit or anything like that no and in a
perverted mind in a perverted world
where i came from i see things for what
they are
you know dr murray said he didn't
[ __ ] go in there
they gave him a lie detector test the
whole [ __ ] thing he said he didn't go
in there
he said he administered 25 [ __ ]
milligrams
you think michael jackson's going to get
up he weighed 130 [ __ ] pound he was
five foot [ __ ] ten or five foot
eleven whatever the [ __ ] he was at the
time of his debt
you think he was gonna get up and throw
[ __ ] more juice in that [ __ ] thing
somebody threw juice in that thing
jesus i'm not no conspiracy theorist
maybe the [ __ ] doctor did [ __ ]
kill him and took the 25 million and
lost his license and got out of debt and
he could still bang women and [ __ ] like
that remember he was banging the two
chinese chicks and flying
he was flying him around the world
slinging dick telling people he's
michael jackson's doctor
so december 13th what goes down my
brother talk to me man ebi ebi5 pbi5
orpheum theater
also pay-per-view on budo videos yes
okay so what goes down talk to me man 16
man tournament
155 pound weight class the best of the
best what are you weighing at right now
155 no [ __ ] so you stay at one this is
what you walk around that i know my
weight you're [ __ ] beautiful
normal weight so
brackets are out
so it's
not easy losing your bracket
on my half of the bracket
um i'm fighting this guy lucas brown
first
and then um
i'd get the winner of eddie cummings and
steve martinez
and then on the other half of my bracket
nathan orchards going against the guy
and then hanaya is going against the guy
and then the winner of those matches
will go against each other and that the
winner of that would go against me so
my lineup would potentially be
if i win my first match
that guy eddie cummings
probably haney yaya or nathan orchard
and then i would be in the finals
rough the rough side of the bracket
it's depending how you look at it
i look
i look at it very differently i don't
even look at it as easy or hard
i look at it as i've been having my eye
on these guys for a long time it's one
way for me to get them all in one night
so what's the purse
uh if you submit everybody
um in regulation
20 grand
and then they have different brackets
yeah and then uh yeah winner take off 20
run so only the winner gets paid
[ __ ] tremendous eddie's doing a great
thing with the cbi he wanted to see him
like i said
from the bottom squad over to highland
over the burbank and now [ __ ] his own
place downtown
he's a bad [ __ ]
what's up with you over there [ __ ]
you're crying cause a new england
patriot no i'm good it's crazy i was
just thinking it's crazy that he's on
ebi5 now like i remember
one yeah this is like a real event now
yeah well i know that ufc fight pass
just bought them somebody oh cool
somebody just picked them up somebody
from the
like those videos where they have all
the archives what's that station where
they have all the archives yeah
ufc
yeah one of those things picked them up
so no they're real they're [ __ ] real
good it's gonna be it's it's fun man
it's a fun format it's
man it kind of strips away
a lot of the problems in jiu jitsu i
think
the fact that you have to finish
just takes away everything nothing else
matters the
passing guard doesn't matter mounting
doesn't matter batman doesn't matter it
doesn't matter no points no nothing no
the only thing that matters is if you
can finish or not
how much simpler is that you know you
can't make it any simpler than that
so the winner can call themselves a jiu
jitsu champion to me guy who submits
everybody and is playing that game
without points because it doesn't matter
joey i can roll with you
for an hour
okay we'll roll an hour
and in that hour
you know
i'm very free with the way i roll so
i'll give you side man i'll give you
mount give you my back give me whatever
just so i can practice my escapes you
know that's kind of my mentality i'm
gonna
let you attack and i can defend be fun
and um
you know though you know you start to
really simplify your game man you start
to go down to the basics what works what
doesn't
because nothing matters unless it's you
know you tapping the guy nothing matters
it makes things so much easier so much
simpler
it's that much more pure jiu-jitsu
that's what you feel yeah well you know
it's it's the journey like i said it's
the journey to the submission what's
going to happen you know in that journey
to the submission
um
because
there's no journey in a point tournament
there's just no journey
do you understand what i'm saying you
you and i shake hands we go it's a
journey what can i get
what are you going to give me your neck
your wrist your elbow your knee your
ankle what what can i get what are you
going to give me and it's positioning
myself and see what are you going to
give me
and that journey
you can't
credit
it's not credit credit's not the right
word
you can't compare
the journey to a point tournament with
the journey to the submission because
there's a finality finality to it you
know what i'm saying
so that journey how do you do it like
i've been studying that i've been
studying eddie cummings a little bit
kind of how he does his leg locks you
know have you ever sat there and watched
how he does it it's crazy it's just like
just looking at it it's a system it's a
system you know it's a system um
wraps your leg slowly starts to climb
and take positions his legs once he
positions the whole time all he's doing
is holding your leg you're not really in
danger
he's positioning himself before he's
wasting his energy trying to finish you
from bad position so he maintains
control first he's very smart
and uh once he positions his legs in the
right in the proper location then he
starts to attack the submission
he understands your counter sequences he
has counters for those and keeps himself
a step ahead
you know
very intelligent very intelligent very
systematic way to attack a problem
only way to beat that is to
systematically figure out a defense
to be in this tournament you have to be
very intelligent
just to be invited to this it's a
different intelligence of jiu jitsu
you pointed out in the beginning you go
to three schools
and those three teach you three basic
moves with one variation different than
the other
because it's an art it's their
expression of the arm
this is the way the arm bar works for
them exactly you know uh
it's uh
like i said i fall in love with it at a
late age
i wish i would have fell in love with it
earlier i wish i could train every day
you know but i can't i have to recover
you know i get
when i go i go i like it i really enjoy
i don't enjoy the top game i enjoy
getting out of the bottom game oh man
you got to come by one day even though
i'm a big fat [ __ ]
yeah when i breathe and i run a rest
i'll get on top of your rest but my
whole thing is to learn how to get out
of my mind you've got to come by and
train with me for an hour
just come by and train with me for an
hour let me show you how simple it is
let me show you how simple it is how
long has your school been open now four
years four years we just expanded it we
just added showers locker room
uh kids room massage room
doubled our mat space
so we uh
looks like the four seasons that plays
you know
it's like nice you know it's very clean
very important that's very clean people
feel safe in my gym i feel safe in my
dream i couldn't have a messy place dude
can't do it so you know
as it is you know you're kind of already
putting yourself in the risk of getting
hurt you don't want to
not get hurt and get some sort of a
freaking skin infection or something you
know very important
so um
so yeah everything we do self-defense
and strike-based jiu-jitsu you can say
right
don't get hit buddy
that's the whole thing it's not getting
hit not getting it's uh like i said just
walk every time i walk out of
a jiu jitsu class
it's the best day of my life because
i've already done the hardest thing i
had to do that day yeah a lot of people
look at it that way and it's funny
because i hate [ __ ] night classes
i [ __ ] hate them
breathe yeah i want to get it over with
i wake up i gotta catch that 11 o'clock
class somewhere and get my dick hard
that's what gets me [ __ ] going for
the day when i do kettlebells i want to
go early 11.
that's seven o'clock the tenth planet
san diego's i love him i love boogie man
martinez and his boys and there's some
crazy mexicans
but six a.m i gotta get up at 3 30.
i gotta drink some coffee i gotta smoke
pot
right or wrong you gotta get balance you
gotta get sea legs i just can't [ __ ]
wake up at ten to six and go [ __ ] raw
i'll puke
i'll [ __ ] puke i [ __ ] puke though
why because it's [ __ ] thinking waking
up and just going right down it's like
when rahegan machado sat in that chair
and said that they would put mats
downstairs they would sleep on the mats
then they would wake up in the middle of
the night and go hey let's go and they
would just i can't [ __ ] do that i
gotta breathe a little bit i gotta go
for a walk and get my energy up i gotta
drink coffee i gotta smoke a few [ __ ]
bongets then i have a great time going
to jiu jitsu
but i don't want to go to jiu jitsu and
struggle from the beginning that's why i
said it takes me a little while to get a
cardio up yeah you know you know what's
funny is
i try to do that with my guys a lot you
know you come in
i don't expect you to be killing people
on day one you know you gotta it's a
it's gotta be a slow pace and and if you
really don't wanna hurt people
you
let them tell you when they're ready to
start sparring so just drill the
positions first you know that's the my
beginner's program there's no sparring
um
until they're ready if they choose to
spar like if a guy's a wrestler i
wrestled through high school okay you're
not gonna let that guy spar
that's the whole point let that guy
spark he kind of understands balance and
movement stuff he's not afraid to get
hurt but people who are afraid i don't
push him this far i'm like
you're going to have to at some point
even if it's positional sparring like
escape the male ready said go
i mean at some point you're going to
have to do it you know but some people
feel more comfortable earlier than
others
you know so you have to understand that
because if you push them to spar and
they get hurt that's the whole point of
them being afraid now you
just screwed yourself because now their
their biggest fear of getting hurt doing
it
just happened so you got to let them be
comfortable i was never a fear getting
hurt i got kicked in the stomach enough
from broken noses
you know what
you know
it's my ankles and [ __ ] i just want to
be able i'll go on stage with a bandage
on my head
you know me i don't give a [ __ ] jack i
don't give a [ __ ] i'll go on stage with
a sling
that wasn't my main thing my main thing
i can't describe to you the anxiety i
would get on the bottom you got me
inside control you you you've got to
come by
you have to buy i i will fix that
problem and then little by little no no
no now i tell people come on let's go
now
that's come on let's go and yeah come on
let's go but there's certain things that
you like if certain things if you take
away certain things from the person on
top just certain things
if they freak out and their your escape
route becomes a lot more obvious you
know what i mean there's certain things
you can't give that guy on top of you
and once you take that away
the escapes will come because there's no
control
you know
it's great when you can do whatever you
want you know
when you're on the bottom and turn and
adjust however you want the problem is
when somebody can hold you there stick
you there
and then position and attack does that
do you understand what i'm saying so
long as you can move on the bottom so
it's a matter of detaching yourself from
your opponent
and understanding the where the
attachment is and and just not giving
the opponent that and once you
understand that
being on the bottom is nothing because
there's no they can't where's the danger
i want to see how you're going to get me
if i keep keep you away from this this
and this go what else do you have
there's nothing
once you shut certain doors
they can't and they can't get through
those doors like everything else the
escapes are coming easy man give me an
example you can't get through the doors
frames
frames certain frames that you use with
your arms you can't get through
you can sit there and push against that
frame as much as you want
you're not going to get through
so you got to make an adjustment you got
to get around this frame
so i'll sit there and i'll frame you
and i'll wait
i'll wait for you to move
see what are you gonna do because i know
because i've been there so many times i
know you're either gonna do a
go this way b do this or c do that i
know what your three options are there's
nothing else you can do that's why i let
people side mount me about me i want to
see something new i want you to catch me
so i can add something else to the
system
so that's how you test the system you
put yourself in that same spot over and
over and over and you start taking notes
they're doing this they're doing this
they're doing this they're doing this
okay first problem they're doing this
what's an easy solution for that
some solutions are easier than others
you know so that's kind of how i look at
jiu jitsu
you know
put yourself deep in a triangle
you circle one way
it's going to get a lot tighter
you circle the other way it gets a lot
looser so what direction what direction
do you think you should circle the way
it gets tighter or looser so you're in a
triangle now
you
already know which way to go
how much more do you think you're going
to escape a triangle just by knowing
which direction you should circle
if you circle one way for sure it's
going to get worse
do you know what direction that is no
wouldn't that be valuable information
yes
i'll show you i'll show you we'll do it
afterwards let's wrap this [ __ ]
up real quick here let's give a shout
out to the sponsors
we got some good sponsors this week
people getting [ __ ] fired up for the
holidays
listen uh for 9 000 years that's how
long uh humans been drinking wine right
that's how long they've been confused
about which wine to drink all right you
got red wine white wine chardonnays
some people get a headache after they
drink wine but for a lot of people
it's just shopping for a wine it gives
you a headache you know you're going to
parties this time of the year a lot of
holiday parties everybody wants to bring
wine you don't know what the [ __ ] to
bring some of it's expensive
you know you don't even have a guarantee
of what you're going to buy
so you know this is what you have to do
do me a favor we joined this new club
called club w and they've they've
changed everything it's easy you go to
clubw.com and you answer six simple
questions
don't
what's this wordly algorithm there they
have an algorithm algorithm their
algorithm creates a palette profile just
for you then they send wine directly to
your door perfectly customized to match
your taste that word always throws me
out at night you know what i'm saying
algorithms
club w is the leading grapes to glass
wine revolution you understand me they
work directly with the vineyards to cut
out the metal man which saves you money
so with club w you get premium wine
customized to your taste and a third of
what you pay at a store are you with me
they even have a no risk 100 money back
guarantee that you'll love what they
send you now do me a favor this is doing
listen holidays are coming you want to
get out of a [ __ ] christmas present
by spending a bunch of money this is the
way to go club w what's a bottle
it's it's like 13 on average but they're
giving it half off the first order
off the first order
you get three four bottles of wine you
go to people's house you give them a
bottle of wine merry christmas you shake
the hand you get the [ __ ] out of there
and they send you oh the wine was
delicious last night you know and also
and here you are johnny interesting you
know johnny interesting you went to
clubw.com you answered the questions
they did the algorithm and they gave you
a pallet profile of what kinds of wine
you'll like with what kinds of food how
to cook the meal they give you a
thousand different things videos
go to club w right now this is what
they're going to do they're going to
give you 50 off your first order when
you go to club w.com
joey listen the holiday seasons are
coming you don't want to show up [ __ ]
empty-handed and if you're like an idiot
like me you don't know what you're doing
when it comes to wine why [ __ ] around
you want to seem interesting you want
people to like you you want people to
think you're hip and you're cool and you
want to keep getting invited to the
party right well and you're going to be
interesting because they ha like their
wines are just for them so that everyone
else is gonna go to the store and get
the same brand of wine you see what i'm
saying
you're gonna be the one with the clue oh
what's that brand that's cool oh my god
where'd you get this look at the label
it's grown in mantis
go to club w dot com get 50 off your
first order and go to club w slash joey
stop wasting time and stop messing
around at retail stores wasting money on
[ __ ] you don't know nothing about go to
clubw.com joey and get 50 off your first
order right why you get me all excited
for number two listen again it's the
holiday season you're gonna what's
seriously i got it already who do you
think you're dealing with some novice
28th street
this for quarter 4 2015.
why you gotta kill me here
all right i've told you about our
sponsor next issue and how it's the best
way to read all your favorite magazines
anytime anywhere well now
next issues name new name is texture and
it has a spectacular new features that
makes it the best reading experience
around
here it is texture is the app that gives
you an all-access pass to the world's
best magazines right on your phone or
tablet browse hundreds of magazines
cherry-pick the articles that interest
you the most you don't got to read [ __ ]
they got nothing to do with you the
texture editorial team
recommends
stories for me daily plus their curated
collections let me dive deeper into the
topics sign up for texture.com right now
and the mere seconds you're going to
gain insight and information to the very
best reads plus exclusive content
if you don't know what i'm sorry about
that
i sound like mickey mouse and he if you
don't know what i'm talking about here
texture is a magazine app and they got
the best magazines around from billboard
to bloomberg business to men's health
the right they got all the sports on the
espn all the espn magazines they got all
the top names uh what's the other one
rolling not rolling stones weight
watchers yoga journal the new yorker the
hollywood reporter vanity fair us weekly
these people are not playing around
texas the real deal holyfield the best
part of the texas offering my listeners
the free trial right now when you go to
texture.com
slash history that's right think about
it you'll gain unrestricted access to
the world's best magazines
from back issues
joey
slash that says techshit.com history i
don't know what
i think it's gonna be joey but
let's go to no no okay okay no i'm sorry
try texture for free right now when you
go to texture.com history think about it
you'll gain unrestricted access to the
world's best magazines from back issues
to the ones on newsstands today all the
way to the back the texture app is the
easiest way to remain culturally curious
with top stories and new and noteworthy
sections updated throughout the day plus
you can share your subscription with the
entire family you can download articles
and whole issues of offline reading so
do me a favor go to texture.com
history and get your free trial right
now it's a great app it's really no it
really is a great app i've heard it from
a thousand people they've hit me back
and said that's a really cool app that's
why i got into it myself my wife is
downloading it for the trip yeah because
i find playing games you get access to
all of those things it's not like you
have to buy them individually when
you're in there those those all those
things if you buy them individually are
expensive so you have access to that
hundreds of those mags speaking of
expensive hit these sigs right now we
got an offer going on 50 off they used
to be 20 what how much a piece 20. 20 a
piece now they're 10 a piece you get
five for 50. hit these things the best
i'm talking about the best electronic
cigarette on the market okay 1200
guaranteed pups we ain't [ __ ] around
here no more you could puff your way
into the new year and beyond all right
five for 50. you get the 24 16 8-0
milligram plus you get a cigar how's
that one for you i'm the best sponsor in
my world honest.com supplements you know
what i'm talking about alpha brain
church in at teddy all right hit these
things place joey's church
get five for 50. all right number three
for honor.com the best the best
supplement you understand me you see me
i'm not sick that's the [ __ ]
new mood uh what is it that's the
immune because i take two of those in
the morning two of those at night people
breathing on me and taking two extra
ones and [ __ ]
how many people breathing on you
make me laugh for lisa
anyway go to honor.com right now and
press splash and get 10 percent off
your first door to [ __ ] so i want
to thank club w i want to thank texture
i want to thank anna and 86 i want to
thank my man
javier vasquez
i had to [ __ ] think about that before
how to focus and watch him on ebi5
december 13th go live to the orpheum
theater or go to
budovidios.com right now and get the
pay-per-view and you can eat chips and
[ __ ] listen it's going to be a great
week of fights you got the ufc on
saturday and you got javier vasquez on
[ __ ] sunday all right so what do you
want from me
i want to thank you again what's the
name of the school
uh gracie jiu jitsu and rancho cucamonga
there we go with the [ __ ] gracie name
everybody's [ __ ] making 10 bucks
it's all over it goes all the way back
to brazil
i [ __ ] love it what's up rose
you're just sitting there relaxing
smiling lee you good i'm great man
you're picking me up tomorrow to call it
a time to go to jiu jitsu i guess so all
right beautiful hang on don't forget
about me i love you guys
see you tuesday or wednesday we haven't
decided yet
uh have a great weekend this weekend
long island saturday night
governors levy town 7 30 and 9 o'clock
show or 9 45 or some [ __ ]
come on down it's a savage dad tour the
beginning
it starts in long island i love you guys
stay black have a great two days
this show is brought to you by club w go
to club w dot com slash joey
to get 50 off of your first order
of the great wine coming from club w and
they're a wine club that changed
everything
they uh have a 100 percent no risk
guarantee that you'll love what they
send you go to clubw.com joey to get 50
off your first order
go to texture.com history
to get a free trial of their new great
new app that
gives you access to hundreds of great
magazines
like espn magazine uh go to texture.com
history
to get a
free trial and go to honorduck.com
uh
get 10 person off
get on dot com east coast church to get
ten percent off
and go to hit e6.com you go with joey's
church
to get 500